there gordon with the headset play did
not come down and travel just through it
if christopher got it curry on [ __ ] good
he's wanted this all night he gets it
again and he takes advantage of it again
down 18
before making this run
on curry puts all the breaks steps back
makes step curry with 25 and counting i
want a nick pick but it looked like that
was an extra step there on the step back
that's what tate does he goes so quick
that the help couldn't get there
and that's what you do oh
wow
vintage
on the rim and curry oh command there
and he is dangerous going to his left
hand that's when the step back
not even halfway through the fourth this
has turned out to be a really
good game
curry stepping back foul on jimmy goes
down curry's in his bag right now
man garrison matthews
not even halfway through the fourth this
has turned out to be a really
good game
curry stepping back balance jimmy goes
down curry's in his bag right now
he has made five of them a season high
his career high is six
oh no
he okay keep playing basketball he's
filling it curry's
chemistry takes time
[Music]
curry right by matthews loops it off the
glass
oh man he's killing it porter jr right
there and that's the left hand of
jayshawn tate
curry wins it to thompson who came back
in eric gordon also back on the floor
back down curry who